فهل تشعر كما يبدو أن
وزير الخارجية يعتقد أن الأمور
تتأرجح بالفعل على الحافة في الوقت الحالي
فيما يتعلق بتوسع الحرب من غزة
وعبر الحدود الشمالية لإسرائيل إلى
لبنان؟ هناك قلق عميق مما
قد يصبح شبه طبيعي من التوترات المتصاعدة  يغلي الأمر
وهذا هو ما وصلنا إليه بالفعل، لقد تعرضنا
لهجمات قادمة من الحوثيين في اليمن
والتي هاجمت أه
الشحن البحري أه لقد رأينا ذهابًا وإيابًا
بين حزب الله وإسرائيل على
مستوى خطير على الرغم من
الرسائل المنتظمة من حسن نصرة بأن هناك
ليس هناك نية لإضفاء الطابع الإقليمي على هذه
الحرب أه لقد كانت هناك هجمات في سوريا
هجمات في العراق أم وهذا يمكن أن
يؤدي إلى سوء تقدير، هل
يمكنني فقط أن أشير وأؤكد فقط على
ما قلته للتو عن ناستالا كيم
جاتاس كما تعلم ومقرها بيروت  لقد
غرد الصحفي: لقد أشار حزب الله وإيران
بوضوح مرارًا وتكرارًا إلى
رغبتهما في تجنب حرب أوسع نطاقًا،
وتواصل إسرائيل اختبار هذا الموقف في
مرحلة ما، وسوف تخطئ في تقدير ذلك
بعد هذه الاغتيالات، أم أننا
تحدثنا للتو عنكم، تعلمون أنكم
تعرفون
المنطقة جميعًا  يعتقد أنهم
يلعبون لعبة ذكية للغاية، كما تعلمون،
مستهدفة ومدروسة للغاية، ولكن هل
سوء التقدير شيء يمكن أن
يحدث؟ أعني أن الإسرائيليين
واللبنانيين قد رأوا بالفعل ما حدث
عبر حدودهم في عام 2006، وعلى الأخص
نعم، أعني أن هذا هو الوضوح  المخاطرة
وهذا كان جزء من أه أنتوني بلينك أه
الهدف الأساسي أه لهذه الرحلة أه
رسالة أن التصعيد ليس في
مصلحة أحد أه المشكلة
أن هناك نوعين أه مختلفين من
الاستراتيجيات و و و الجداول الزمنية
الجارية في المنطقة لا دولة أه  لا يوجد أي جهة
دولة أو غير دولة في المنطقة
تدفع فعلاً نحو التصعيد بينما
أه الحكومة الإسرائيلية أه تحاول
إعادة ضبط أ مستويات الردع لديها منذ
7 أكتوبر وهذا يتطلب منهم أه
ليس فقط محاولة أه قطع رأس
قيادة حماس التي نعرفها  بعد 94 يومًا
من 7 أكتوبر، لم يتمكنوا من
فعل سوى محاولة صد
حزب الله والتوضيح أن
حدودهم آمنة، وهذا ما
يحدث الآن بينما بقية
المنطقة سواء كانت إيران أو حزب الله.  سواء كان الأمر كذلك، فإن
الشركاء العرب الأوسع
للولايات المتحدة ليس لديهم مصلحة في رؤية
هذا الانفجار ينفجر لأن هذا قد
يأخذ الأمور إلى مدار جديد.